Time. It's the one thing every AppSec team is short on.
Juggling manual scans, discovering vulnerabilities, and struggling to keep up with expanding web applications.
Burp Suite Enterprise Edition, our advanced DAST scanner, is here to change that.
Giving you the power to scale your security testing, reclaim your time, and finally get ahead of the vulnerability curve.
Start by organizing your entire web application portfolio with our centralized command center.
It empowers you to schedule automated, recurring DAST scans, capturing low-hanging fruit effortlessly.
Freeing your team from tedious manual tasks and allowing them to focus on what matters most, fixing critical vulnerabilities.
Integrate DAST scanning seamlessly into your development pipeline with CI-driven scans.
Catch vulnerabilities early, before they reach production, and empower developers to address issues quickly and efficiently.
This isn't just about finding vulnerabilities faster. It's about preventing them entirely.
Consume the results where you need them most with our powerful GraphQL, API, and fluid integrations.
Whether it's JIRA or your custom vulnerability management platform, Burp Suite Enterprise Edition ensures your security insights flow effortlessly into your existing workflows.
This means faster remediation, improved collaboration, and a truly integrated approach to application security.
Take control of your application security with Burp Suite Enterprise Edition.
Request a 14-day free trial and see the difference for yourself.
The next step is to get the information security.